back here at home the dow had its best
day since march
gaining 587 today the s p 500 was up 58
the nasdaq rose
111. president biden is turning his
focus to the domestic economy tonight
after his big foreign policy trip
last week white house correspondent
peter ducey joins us live on the north
lawn
with that good evening peter good
evening brett the white house tells us
that when
the president met with financial
regulators today they told him they
think the economy is in good shape and
they
told him they are having success making
progress using regulations to address
climate change the way the president has
ordered and while that huddle was
happening here at the white house
officials sent the vice president to
pennsylvania
we are very proud that our
administration will probably be the most
pro-union of any we've seen before away
from cameras at the white house
president biden hosted the federal
reserve chair jay powell for the first
time
the president's view is this is a
routine meeting with financial
regulators to get an update on
management of the economy and arranged
and making credit accessible
not going great according to critics
concerned about inflation the cost is
rising through the roof i mean you can't
buy a home
uh the cost of home prices and remember
a home
is core part of the american dream so
what does that mean you basically get
priced out
of owning part of the american dream
hoping to fill empty job openings as
pandemic conditions improve
a dozen states have already said they're
going to stop offering the 300
a week in enhanced unemployment benefits
and roughly two dozen more states may
soon follow suit you're seeing states
that are going to forego
that the unemployment claims are going
down and the opportunities to work
are increasing it's a great opportunity
for folks who are ready to get back to
work
what does the white house think about
that so we know governors are going to
make their decisions
we continue to believe that with more
than seven million people out of work
that there's still additional assistance
we should give to the american public
white house officials see an
infrastructure package
as a big jobs creator and they want
movement within weeks
he does not feel the time is unlimited
and while the president's preference is
a deal
with republicans there are multiple
democrats working on plan b's
what i think the president has done is
given us a blueprint as to where we want
to go
so sanders is now trying to fold
multiple unpassed biden proposals into a
6 trillion dollar
mega package he hopes could be passed
with democrats only
if something six trillion dollars big
makes it to the president's desk but
would he sign it or is that too big
well first we're not quite there yet
that
is not a no so now a president who once
distanced himself from sanders during
the primaries by saying
i'm not a socialist i beat the socialist
is keeping an open mind about his
legislative
ideas brett peter what are the prospects
for this voting rights bill
to pass when the senate brings it up
tomorrow very slim
brett the votes just are not there for
chuck schumer who wants the for the
people act
to be brought up for a vote tomorrow and
that's because lawmakers on both sides
of the aisle
have problems with it democrats of
course are believing that this could be
a
counter balance on state voting laws
they think are too restrictive but it
really does not have much hope of
passing
until major changes are made including
possibly adding a voter id
requirement and if it's going to pass it
might require more input
from this place because remember earlier
this month
the president made voting rights part of
the portfolio
of the vice president kamala harris all
right looks like some storm clouds
rolling into the white house there we'll
see if it happens politically too
peter thanks